as it happens you've been working with
parameters for quite some time
they just haven't had that name okay so
what I want you to think of and I want
you to I just quickly draw from these
two axes what I want you to think about
is our old trusty friend the unit circle
here's the unit circle sensor origin
radius radius one now the reason why you
can remember from hopefully last seed
but also this year when we're doing
training the reason why the inner circle
is so crucial is because it gives us a
better way to define these guys rather
than be lame and thinking about just
right angle triangles okay right a
quadratic was a very limited for example
you come out to zero degree angle in
turbine a good for you or you can't have
a 90 degree angle in a right angle
triangle or you kind of have anything
bigger than right angle in a right angle
triangle because you break the egg with
some of the triangle so that's why we
said this from the positive x-axis going
that way okay and you put up an angle
like that you call the a goofy top right
what you create is a right angle
triangle that you can see the trig
functions in from which you get the fact
that you can say the coordinates of that
point of the circumference of the unit
circle can be expressed right just like
aa three clubber for all rights the unit
circle 1/2 comma number three or two
something like that okay
instead you can say look this point the
X&Y coordinates are not so much related
to each other and they are related to
this angle and the angle is the
parameter it's the one now but it's
actually changing things so as I always
say let's get this formally down
underneath this now now that we have the
language powerful enough to describe it
okay in the inner circle what you've got
is a new third measurement feeder right
theta is the parameter upon which your x
and y coordinates get their values right
there x and y coordinates can all be
could both be expressed in terms of
theta upon which the x and y coordinates
depend
okay so no way of saying this is right
if I said to you okay I want you to know
where I am on the unit circle what I
could provide to you is two numbers I
could provide you an excellent why okay
I could say all right
I had a zero negative one that's this
point down here so two numbers that told
me where I am okay but if I know what
the parameter is if I understand this
system and the way that it functions
just like my ice cream and sunscreen and
temperature okay I only need one number
I only need the parameter if I just say
I'm a 270 degrees on the unit circle
that conclusively tells you where I am
just like if I told you the temperature
that would conclusively tell you with
just a single number what the sales of
ice cream and sunscreen were like okay
so the way that we write this is like
you're used to seeing it up there in the
coordinates okay I would say x equals
cos theta y equals sign okay so because
this is a pair of equations that
involves the parameter theta right
we call this pair of equations down here
parametric equations they're equations
just like you see metal but they have a
parameter in them okay so they're fourth
parametric equations now you know the
unit circle you met the unit circle way
before this idea of like theater and
reminding all that kind of thing we know
that these parametric expressions are
not the only way to express this set of
points right what's the equation of the
unit circle with just X's and Y's x
squared plus y squared equals 1 exactly
because the radius over here is 1 square
right
so this equation here because just X's
and Y's it's just the coordinates in our
Cartesian system right this is called
the Cartesian equation these two things
are equivalent to each other in exactly
the same way that I guess we could say
up here
I kind of have Cartesian equations
inverted commas for sunscreen and ice
cream equations in two variables whereas
down here these guys because they
introduced
temperature these are the parametric
equations see there's the parameter
right and of course you guys know this
this actually worked because close
square plus sign spread of course it
goes to one right so there's the example
you've already been working it for a
long time okay but you can do this
process go from here to here right you
can do that for a whole variety of
functions right so this is cool lots of
words doing the same thing this is
called this is called parametrizing an
equation right as in introducing a
parameter okay that's what happens when
you go from just X's and Y's to
introducing a tea or a theta or whatever
else whereas going in the opposite
direction right sometimes you get given
the parameters there could be a
situation where I know two things both
relate to one thing I can if I like cut
out the middleman I just want the two
things in their relationship to each
other
maybe I don't care about temperature or
theta okay so going in the other
direction is cold because you're getting
rid of the prandtl it's called
eliminating the parameter okay so if you
go from how much equations and then do
something to it like as we've seen in
this case squaring the two x and y is in
their hands yeah right that will get rid
of the parameter if on the other hand
you want to add the premise so you can
work with them independently then that's
paratransit you'll be asked to do both
okay sir what kind of shape of women
looking at much basically parabolas
alright
so you can parametrize
more or less anything okay what I'm
going to give you is I'm going to give
you a pair of equations and x and a y
equation have any twins or the problem
you go to your uniform that's a little
bit unusual but the reason for this
particular form will become clear as we
move forward further into this okay and
also as we bring in our friend calculus
so yes you should you should recognize
some weird things anyhow if I put these
two together right I have the parametric
equations here right so I'm interested
in what Cartesian equation corresponds
to this pair of things by the way just
before we leave off these guys right
what this is saying
just like on the unit circle remember I
said oh there's a locus definition and
we usually say on at some point P that
moves and it's called ex-wife it's at XY
well now I have values for x and y so
stem say this which is Cartesian I was
saying this which is parametric okay
same idea just expressed differently so
how would I go about going from here to
here right and combining these in a way
that gets rid of the T how do I get rid
of the T well let's just take this is
our equation one and equation two if
you're trying to eliminate a variable
out of a set of simultaneous equations
because that's that's all that is right
you can either use elimination or
substitution right based on what we've
got here I'm guessing substitution would
be a more helpful kind of thing it's not
like I've got a minus B a plus B you
just add a minute
okay I'm gonna have to do something else
so let's take a question one let's
rearrange it if I make tea the subject
so I can substitute into the other guy
right T is going to be equal to what
what do I divide both sides my ex I'm su
a right okay so I can take this guy I'll
call this one ain't right I'm going to
put that into the equation - let's do
this substitution right there's my tea
in there so Y will be equal to a times X
on to a swear I've just replaced the two
it's all I've done
and of course simplify this is pretty
straightforward you've got a x squared
on the top what's on my denominator 4a
squared don't forget to square both of
them 4a squared you can see that I've
got an A on the top and a pair of A's on
the bottom so that one will cancel and
we'll leave one behind and you're like I
recognize this guy right this is our old
friend X square equals 4 and y okay so
this is the reason why I gave you this
particular pair of parametric equations
because they give us that particular
Cartesian equation which is useful to
work with under mockers now there are
even more cool reasons from why this
pair of equations is what we're going to
use they will come out in their coming
days